foreign
Folks at this time I would like to call
this session of the state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs executive
session two order
uh I do want to thank the speaker's
office I have a gavel uh that looks
wonderful so if anybody at the speaker's
office is watching thank you very
appreciative of that okay so we've got
uh seven measures that we're going to
exec today the order is somewhat to to
be determined we want to adjust to
accommodate some schedules here
um before we get to a specific measure
though I want I have some folks here
including representative uh
Reed
representative Reed
um and I would like to give her and uh
Sam
um fieldman is an attorney uh so Ellen
and Sam and I know uh Sam you have to
get on a national Zoom or something
shortly
so I want to invite both of you up front
uh to just uh speak to us about the the
two HBS we have two HBS two house bills
today they both deal with delegates to a
convention Convention of the states or
or
uh 392 the description refers to a
constitutional convention so I'm going
to uh throw it to you both and go ahead
and explain to us uh the Amendments and
what we need to know before we take up
those two HBS
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members uh for the record my
name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 new market and new fields
and I guess I'll start with with the
overview to refresh everybody's uh
memory and I have my legal counsel Hill
here to correct me Wherever I May air so
uh 269 and 392 were two separate bills
dealing with how we handle delegates to
conventions 269 which for disclosure I
was not a co-sponsor of not because I
opposed it just I didn't happen to be a
co-sponsor of deals with conventions
interstate and Interstate conventions
very broadly does not call for election
of delegates it covered uh what we call
Article 5 conventions sometimes we
casually refer to them as constitutional
conventions there's a little Nuance
there but
um it covered that but because it was
dealing with all these conventions it
kind of dealt on what I would call a
more shallow level and when we're
talking about about regular Interstate
policy making conventions
other other kinds of conventions like
that you may not need like a lot of
depth but if you're dealing with the
Constitution and changing the
Constitution of the country we wanted to
make sure that we have really strict
rules on how we select delegates how we
pull delegates how we nullify their
votes which is where 392 comes in so
while
269 is Broad and shallow 392 is very
narrow specific to Article 5 conventions
but gets far deeper and far more
controls over those delegates so 269 I
think there was broad support for this
was the one that I was running around
last week getting the amendment together
for you all so at the request of the
chair I put the amendment in and that's
the amendment you see before you the the
amendment
does two things the first is it exempts
the uniform law commission we understood
that perhaps the executive branch would
have found including the uniform law
commission objectionable and so we
Exempted that the other thing that it
does is the very last line the
provisions of this chapter shall not
supersede any provisions of RSA 667
667 is the RSA that is impacted by the
other Bill
392 which is why the chair had me go and
have this amendment drafted to make sure
that these two bills could pass without
interfering with each other so that
final line in this amendment on 269 is
what does that so this would if passed
as amended 269
restrict delegates to all these
conventions
um with the the measures that are in
that bill
which is not specifically that's for
appointing delegates but we want to make
sure that for constitutional conventions
or Article 5 conventions that we are
electing delegates and that we have
really good control over those delegates
so that's the amendment on this that
exemption on 667 that's where we go over
to 392 392 is the one that's specific
but deep
and that impacts as you can see 667 and
all of the election language in HB 392
is in RSA 667.
the only changes in the amendment on 392
were the ones that were brought up
during hearing the first change at the
top changes from one delegate per
congressional district plus one
Statewide to two delegates per
Statewide
did I sorry I thought I heard you okay
and then the second part there's two
paragraphs at the bottom the original
Bill had an unspecified penalty for any
delegate who violated their oath an
unspecified excuse me is unspecified
felony penalty the committee sounded
during the hearing that that may be
considered too strict so we have
separated out knowingly and purposefully
which is very common in criminal law so
that if they knowingly which is the
lower culpable State
um violate their oath they are guilty of
a misdemeanor a
and if they purposefully which is that
very high prosecution has to prove
intent For Thought planning
um that that is a felony B which is the
lower of the two felonies I think that
maxes out at five years
so uh I have done what the committee has
asked in preparing these amendments I'll
just turn it over to my my legal counsel
uh yeah I just want to clarify uh one
thing the um 269 does include the the
provision that is widely considered the
gold standard and single strongest
protection over any uh delegate uh to
whom there is a limiting instruction
which is that the their vote would be
invalidated and replaced this language
has been used in both the Article 5
ratification conventions in 1933 as well
as the Electoral College uh in which
context it was upheld unanimously by the
Supreme Court both versions include that
uh the uh it's all of the other aspects
of regulating the Article 5 proposing
convention uh that are included in in
392 that are not in 269 which includes
elections both for the uh the delegates
as well as their alternates and some
more details on how that mechanism Works
to ensure uh that the invalidation
process runs smoothly and uh seamlessly
and I would just end with
um both of these are neutral on the
concept of calling for an article five
but we know that we may very well be
pulled into an article 5 convention
without us having ever passed any call
ourselves although that did just pass
this committee so
um I think we're about six or eight
states away from the balanced budget
amendment call passing depends on on how
we count but the point is is that both
of these simply put the procedure in
place so that we're not left in the
Lurch when that happens
thank you representative and thank you
Mr fieldman you were at the big session
we had at Repsol you've been here before
and thank you for all the uh time you
put in to try to explain to us so we
understand better
this process related to Article Five
conventions now this spot this committee
has already voted 13 to 5 to move hc-1
hcr1 on so both of these
HBS the only two HBS we have today house
bills uh both concerned
um the delegate issues and we'll take
them up separately uh
um in a short time I want to welcome the
subs we have today uh representative
Brennan thank you for subbing uh
representative Platt is here
um
let me see uh representative Fox thank
you representative Hicks thank you for
being here
um represent Lundgren is supposedly
inbound and I have not heard from
representative Katya chorus uh
so thank you for your service and
oh representative Thomas I welcome I'm
glad very glad you're here especially
glad you're here okay uh thank you both
and you're welcome I know uh Mr Spielman
you've got a zoom or something
representative welcome to stay around if
if you are here uh I may uh because I
can uh ask you to comment or explain
something once we get to both of those
hb's if you're still here and if there
are questions while you're there does
anyone have any questions for
representative Reed uh yes uh
representative Platt just uh ask whether
it makes a difference which one is taken
up first it does not
um neither of these bills as amended
would conflict with each other so indeed
it wouldn't matter which one we passed
on the floor but it doesn't matter which
one passes in committee first at any
rate what matters is what the floor in
the Senate do which one final which one
gets signed by the governor first
typically that means the second bill
that gets signed takes precedent as I
understand the procedure we have a
parliamentarian here but it doesn't
matter which one the committee passes
first as I understand it having said
that they do not Conflict at all
okay thank you again so let's get to
this at the top of the lineup there used
to be more questions Mr chairman no
sorry did someone yes
very quickly I just want to insert if
anyone does not I tried to make sure
everybody had copies of the Amendments
if you don't I can make sure you have
them and also I will be staying for the
duration of the executive session and I
am at the committee's service go ahead
thank you rat breed I just want to
clarify for because
um I and I really found what the your
conclusion very helpful that but I've
heard some people say that they oppose
retinal's bill because they oppose an
article 5 convention so I just want to
make it crystal clear that in your
opinion rep read this isn't about
whether or not we have an article 5
convention but do you believe this just
makes it more democratic if we do that
is precisely the case so as I said
neither of these bills either as
introduced or as amended take a position
on calling for an article five I think
there is some and I would I might
categorize it as a bad faith argument in
that if we pass something that makes it
less scary then we might more easily get
to an article 5 convention but the point
is we may get pulled into that whether
or not New Hampshire wants to and we
have to have control troll over our
delegates 392 allows for the election
unlike 269 the election the direct
election of delegates their alternate
alternates and has very strict controls
over if they violate their oath and go
off topic so you are right is far more
small D Democratic in that sense uh also
I provided uh last week when I testified
on this bill a letter from uh then
Senator Joe Biden president of course
also calling for the passage of this
type of Regulation at that time it was
uh Congressional regulation but it's the
same type of added protection even
though he did not support having an
article 5 convention he did support the
idea of having the regulations in place
in case one occurs I may be a little bit
out of my legal depth but I understand
there's been many attempts at a
congressional control over the delegates
in Article 5 convention and the my
understanding is that Congress this
really doesn't play a part in that that
it's strictly the states that can
control their delegates
maybe states can control only states can
control their delegates Congress plays a
role in calling the convention itself
thank you again to the two of you any uh
representative gagne
probably a question to the chair uh
does everyone on this committee right
now have the amendment for 392 and two
is there one for 269
yes or amendments for both of those
measures uh that have been emailed to
everyone in the committee and uh
representative just passed out a higher
copy right I did but I don't think it
made it to that specific Corner because
you started before I could finish
passing it out and I didn't want to
approach that's why I need a hard copy I
will I will do that as soon as I'm done
here
or I can do that right now uh sure if if
you could get that to us any other
questions for Mr fieldman or
representative Reed
okay uh I want to get right to this uh
especially with one of the sponsors here
in case we have technical questions I I
will say as long as I can I have a
hearing in Washington state at 11 but
I'll stay as long as I can if there's
any further questions
thank you for that
and
thank you representative Reed all right
so let's get right two three nine two
and I'm looking for a motion on this uh
representative Manion do you have a
motion sorry yeah uh motion OTP
second
I'd like to introduce the amendment okay
okay stand by on that if you would uh
the motion is to OTP on 392 by
representative Manion and uh thank you
by seconded by representative gagne
thank you representative massamila for
stepping up to do the clerking uh sort
of Kerry uh could not be here so we will
we will help you and we will we will get
this done in the best way thank you for
uh stepping up
okay so uh we have a motion and you've
asked to uh speak to an amendment
uh yeah so I'd like to uh let's
introduce Amendment uh zero five
sorry zero four five two as an amendment
uh go ahead and uh speak to your
amendment I will second in case it needs
a second
so so you're you've made a motion to for
us to consider your Amendment and
representative gagne has seconded that
so go ahead and speak to your amen
amending motion so as it was uh defined
so the the amendment here clarified the
election process here for the
representatives of the districts or the
uh the representative districts with the
how the delegates will be elected and
the second component here is that it's
uh redefining there was some concern
from this committee about the severity
of the punishments uh that they were
scaled back a bit uh depending on
whether it's knowingly or willing or um
yeah intentionally purposefully uh went
against their uh intended uh role at the
delegation
thank you representative uh would anyone
else like to speak to this amendment
representative Charlotte
uh thank you Mr chairman I know the
member introduces in all good faith uh
but I am going to vote against it and
the reason being is the penalty of being
a Class B uh felony and a class B felony
Mr chairman under New Hampshire law is
three and a half to seven years in the
state prison and it's a fine line
between purposefully and knowingly
committing an act and I would hate to
see anybody fulfilling this Civic
obligation by serving on a convention
being charged with that serious and
offense for something they probably may
not have realized they were doing so
I'll be voting against the amendment
thank you Mr chairman thank you for that
representative this did come up when we
visited this the first time I think
representative gagne it might have been
him uh spoke about concerns about the
misdemeanor versus the felony it was
Finney was very concerned about the
severity right okay representative
Infinity so it's something we have
talked about before I mean I understand
that is a concern for some other
anything else other comments on the
motion
um I will just make one and then I'll
ask the clerk to call the roll
um I'm going to support the amending
motion and the
the bill itself
for the reasons that uh the co-sponsor
already touched on
this committee has already passed and
has sent eights see our uh see I went to
the house floor
and I think what representative Reed uh
said is very important whether you like
a uh the concept of an article 5
convention or not uh if it someday is
thrust upon us if it happens Could
Happen people certainly want to some
people want to make it happen
my position
Echoes representative reads in that we
want to have the best definition that we
can have for our delegates in the
delegate process and the delegate issues
and and this does that so whether you
love the concept of a convention or not
uh I think that the amendment in the
Bill
provides some safeguards for us down the
road if this ever happens that's where I
am at on this anything else
oh I just think it was made very clear
that it's purposefully like a very high
bar because it's our most essential
document
I think representative uh anything else
if not I'm going to ask Madam clerk to
read the role on the amendment
the amendment is zero four five two H
and the motion is ought to pass
representative Rollins yes
Lundgren is not here cats of course is
not here
representative Harley
yes
representative gagne yes
representative representative piamonte
yes
representative Platt yes
representative Thomas yes
representative Manion yes
representative shurtleff
represented do I call me
representative massamila yes
representative Boris
yes
representative thoughts
representative Hicks yes
representative toll
yes
representative Judy's not here
representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill
yes
representative Siebert
and the chair
yes
16 years in one name
thank you madam chair of Madam Clerk
um
16 to 1 uh potentially on does anyone
object to this going on consent
yes
uh I'm Mr chairman we voted on the
amendment now oh I'm sorry yes yes I
have no objective consent okay yes
you're exactly right yes that was the
amending motion thank you and what we
need to do now having passed the
amendment is we need to vote on the
measure itself as amended this would be
an otpa motion on HP 392 it does have an
FN
so that uh prop probably would uh
preclude it going on consent if I
understand the the rules correctly
so this would not be eligible for
consent because of the FN piece of this
uh
so back to representative man your
motion is now
OTP as amended yes yes my motion is OTP
I'm in and we have the same second for
that uh representative gagne again any
further discussion on this measure is
otpa
okay and I will uh make one more comment
and we're gonna go from this after this
vote uh to HB 269 which is a kind of a
sister measure to 392 and I just want to
say that I uh spent considerable time on
both of these I pushed out both of these
to numerous people uh for their input on
both the amendment and both of these uh
HBS that have to do with delegates and
uh I just did not receive any Red Flags
uh
back from other people all the different
places that I push it out I know you all
looked at it as well
so
um that said uh the motion is otpa uh
Madam clerk if you could read the Rope
um representative Rollins yes
representative Thomas
yes
representative Harley yes
representative gagne yes
representative piamonte
yes representative Platt
yes representative Manion yes
representative shurtleff yes
clerk votes yes representative Boris
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative toll
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative Siebert
represent Mr chair
yes
you missed one representative
representative Fox yes Lundgren
you will hear this one
oh okay sorry representative Fox
and representative Fox votes
yes yes
um
foreign
yes
thank you madam Clerk
okay as I just said I would
the count was 16 to zero
okay I'd like to now as I said go to the
system measured 392 which is two six
nine uh we have had a hearing on this
before we recessed the hearing to get
some answers and also to allow for an
amendment so this we've already
discussed this in committee there is an
amendment
um pending but we need a motion and I'm
going to again look to uh representative
Manion again uh motion to OTP
motion is to OTP second
and again the amendment discussion to
follow okay so uh motion of OTP by
representative Manion the second Again
by representative gagne representative
mannion indicated he wanted to speak on
an amending or have an amending motion
uh go ahead uh representative
yes
amendment number is zero three three
zero eight
three zero three three one zero h
uh thank you representative uh any other
discussion on the amendment
okay seeing nine uh Madam chair the uh
motion is to uh
pass the amendment the amendment again
is zero three three zero H if you would
read that role
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren
representative Thomas yes
representative Harley
representative gagne
representative piamonte
yes
representative Platt yes yes
representative Manion yes
representative shirtleff yes
clerk votes yes
representative Boris yes
representative Fox
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative toll yes
representative Brennan
yes
representative O'Neill
representative Siebert
yes
represented the chair
18 years and zero Nays
did the original measure have a fiscal
note
did someone have that right in front of
them it did right
okay so that would not go on consent
despite the final vote you said it was
18-0 yeah
that was for the amendment yes once
again as was the case last time that was
the amending motion which passed that
was uh zero three three zero
uh now uh back to the
original HB which the motion now
represent manual would be OTP otpa yes
any further discussion
seeing none
uh I believe did you second that
representative gagne I thought you did
second thank you to confirm that uh so
the motion again was by
otpa by reps and Manion representative
gagne again seconded that and the number
the number again is uh the amendment
number is zero three three zero H and
what's the bill number uh the bill
number is hb269r
with an FN
so we will have the role on the motion
of otpa
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes
representative Harley yes representative
gagne yes
representative piamonte
yes
representative Platt yes
representative mannion yes
representative shurloff yes the clerk
votes yes representative Boris yes
representative Fox
yes representative Hicks yes
representative toll
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill
representative Siebert
and the chair
yes
okay
18 years is zero names
thank you madam Clerk
okay going down the uh docket so to
speak HCR 7 uh is there that's the
measure the resolution concurrent
resolution recognizing nowhegan band of
the classic Abenaki Nation
um
is there
emotion like I make make a motion ideal
okay represent represent Manion again
stepping up and his motion is to itl is
there a second for that second is from
representative shortliff thank you uh
representative shurliff uh represent
meaning would you care to speak to your
motion of itl yeah
um so during the testimony there was a
lot of heated discussion on on both
sides and I I don't believe that this
resolution is the way to go about this
recognition process I feel like we're
getting in the middle of like a family
squabble uh and making any kind of
decision from the state level is not the
right way to go about it perhaps uh we
can introduce a bill sometime to have
the the Council of uh First Nations that
we have uh discuss this and find a
mechanism to do so but I don't think
this house resolution is the way to go
thank you representative representative
shirtle if we're here to speak to your
second I would just concur with
representative Manion with his comments
and I know the sponsors had the best of
intentions I was concerned about the
mechanism being hcf being a house
concurrent resolution and not involved
in the executive branch and I couldn't
say any better than representative Mania
has already spoken thank you Mr chair
thank you representative Sherlock does
anyone else want to speak to the itl
motion
uh representative O'Neill want to speak
briefly and say I think I think I speak
for many of us when I say that we
recognize how important it is to
recognize these populations
unfortunately I think several of us may
feel that this isn't the right way to go
about it but we understand the
importance of it as well
thank you representative
anyone else
I'll simply add that those of us and I
know the folks in the room if you looked
at the portal and also the emails that
we got that were they were very much
split there was some very strong uh
messages on both sides and uh that was a
concern for me was that there was such a
split
on that other comments
seeing No Hands uh Madam clerk the
motion on hcr7 is the itl and if you
would read the role please
representative Rollins
yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Harley yes representative gagne yes
representative piamonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative Manion yes representative
shurlive yes clerk votes yes
representative Boris yes representative
Fox
yes representative Hicks yes
representative toll yes representative
Brennan
yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative sieber
and the chair yes
18 years zero Nays
that is one I think we can put on
consent with no objection if there is no
objection
okay thank you uh you can mark that as
consent uh Mr Vice chair and Madam Madam
clerk right below HCR 7 is hr7 house
resolution 7 calling for the federal
government to preserve and protect
Medicare and Social Security without
cuts to benefits that's a description of
the resolution
um is there emotion
on this uh on this resolution
I know about to pass
representative uh Gagney moves OTP on to
pass is there a second second Mr chair
Representative shurtliff makes the
second
um
representative gagne would you care to
speak to your
OTP motion
while I know that there are problems
with Social Security and Medicare
because if the money's involved and it
probably needs some tweaking but to um
diametrically opposed to getting rid
of
Medicare and Social Security
especially with cuts and benefits I'm
myself I am on a uh I I'm old enough to
have Social Security and Medicaid and uh
to cut those benefits would for many
people would uh older Americans would
not be to their benefit and
two hours either so I will be voting to
pass this house resolution
thank you representative gagne
representative would you care to speak
to your second
I would just agree with my friend from
Manchester and echoed the same cut well
I don't feel the problems with Social
Security uh I do think that this is a
noble uh motion and that we should
support it
thank you I'm Sam sherliff would anyone
else care to speak to the motion of OTP
seeing No Hands Madam cleric Let's uh go
back and do another roll on OTP for HR
7.
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Harley yes representative gagne yes
representative Piemonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes clerk votes yes
representative Boris yes representative
Fox yes representative Hicks yes
representative toll
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative candid um of Neil threw
me off to you yes
representative Siebert and
[Music]
um Mr chair yes
so we have 18 to zero
and without objection we can put we'll
put that on consent if there is no
objection
thank you all
um Mr chairman yes
um as you know I've got to be over the
speaker's office at 11. I wonder if we
could take the uh the retain Bill up now
before I leave sure if that'd be
convenient for the chair sure we have
three measures to go uh HR 15 HR 16 in
the uh measure that we're we want to uh
bring back
so that would be hcr4
we took this up earlier and we voted to
retain but we held on to that we did not
submit the uh the retain motion which
enables us to uh revisit it but we need
a motion to reconsider I motion
reconsider thank you represent meaning
for jumping right in there again I will
second it and thank you for jumping in
again keeping this moving so we have a
a motion to reconsider hcr4 and we need
to uh do you want to speak to your
motion absolutely so I I'm I support uh
term limits I would very much like to
see this uh be reconsidered uh by the
committee we should make a vote on it I
saw the vote get a throw we just passed
the concerns people had about a
Convention of States uh delegates
running amongst we just we got those
through so I figured we should do this
now
uh just a moment uh the secondary was
that uh oh that was you no that was a
representative gagne again yes
representative do you want to speak to
your second
uh no not at this time representative
Charlotte
um Mr chairman I do object to the
reconsideration uh the reconsideration
of retaining this bill in but I would
not I'll vote Yes as a courtesy to the
member to have it heard by the full
committee
thank you for that representative
shortliff any other
anyone else want to speak to the motion
to reconsider
hcr4
seeing No Hands then uh Madam clerk on
the motion to reconsider hearing
committee acr4
oh I actually have something to say I
Heard a Voice from somewhere
representative like there's an amendment
uh before we can take up any Amendment
uh we need to bring the bill the res the
measure back uh into play oh I see what
you're saying okay sorry if if we don't
vote to uh reconsider then it's moot to
uh talk about the amendment so we need
to see if we can reconsider it first
uh thank you for that question
any other questions
and if not again the motion is to
reconsider
uh
hcr4 and Madam clerk when you're ready
if you could
read the rule for that one
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes
representative Harley yes representative
gagne yes representative pierremonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative mannion yes
representative shurless yes
representative me yes
representative Boris yes
representative Fox
yes representative Hicks yes
representative toll
yes representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill
representative sieber
okay the 18 years
miss Mr chair
yes
and there are 18 years and zero Nays
thank you madam clerk so this means that
we have agreed to reconsider this
measure and now we would need a uh
emotion on the floor OTP thank you
represent Manion uh OTP I will again
second this all right moving right along
uh again representative Manion yes
a
wait one
all right as I said uh we have uh we
have an amendment as well uh standby on
that uh
we have
agreed to reconsider the
measure now before we can entertain a
which I was starting to look for which I
was a little bit premature before we can
ask for that
um
motion for OTP or ATL or whatever we
have to address the fact that now that
the measures back in play the motion the
previous motion was retained we need to
uh
un retain it so to speak
um
and we're fortunate the house clerk is
here to make sure that we have this
protocol correctly and no unretained is
not a formal motion but
the proper Motion in this case would be
to uh
vote down retain okay it's similar to
unretained but we need a motion uh if
you would rips a man into a low down
retain vote down retain
in a second
yes second
right the motion on this measure that
we've agreed to reconsider is now to
vote down the previous uh uh
recommendation which was to retain
representative Charlotte
thank you Mr chairman I would ask the
committee to vote no on the motion uh we
did the right thing in retaining this
bill
under our house rule house rule 45
cities one which says that when we
retain a bill no action B shall be taken
till the second half of the biennium
because this bill was still in the
possession of the committee and not
had not gone to the clerk's office
it was still in play and could be acted
on
under our
it's always been traditional to read
when we reconsider a retention motion
that there must have been some
significant change or some piece of
information that came forward before
that bill went to the clerk's office
with all due respect to the prime
sponsor the only information we have is
they want to change the title as
Shakespeare said arose By Any Other Name
it still arose this is still the same
bill that we retained and I would ask
the committee to vote no on the motion
take care of some short left uh other
questions or comments on this
uh said by the house clerk is and is in
the house
again
okay
yes
sure well these are
guarantee it
the prime sponsor is here I may as a
courtesy may want him to speak to this
I'm also going to ask you for
clarification purposes uh the house
clerk is here as well so just so we're
clear on how what this process is and to
uh and I want to speak to representative
shirtle's comment
um in a few moments uh Mr Mr Clark thank
you thank you Mr chairman just
procedurally you voted yes to
reconsideration so you are now back at
the last motion that was adopted and
that is the retained motion it's not to
undo the retained motion the motion is
to retain a yes vote means to retain a
no vote means to not retain and consider
another action
so a yes is to keep retained a no means
to take some subsequent action just to
just to clarify uh we we can't undo the
motion only vote it down and Mr chairman
just to follow yes having our friend uh
the prime sponsor speak on this we are
an executive session uh the question is
before us and I think it should be a
simple up and down vote by the committee
as I said I voted as a courtesy for the
member for us to discuss this but I
think now uh we should vote on whether
to retain it or not I'd ask the
committee to vote Yes to please retain
this bill
think represent sir lift we will have
that uh vote on the motion and I think
it should be clear to everyone if you
want
the measure to stay retained now that
we've brought it back into play that you
will vote yes if you want to not
maintain the retain motion you would
vote no and that and then if if the no
was knows were to Prevail then we could
entertain another motion if the yes is
Prevail then we will be staying with
retention uh representative Platt last I
know the it was a motion on the floor
and seconded to unretain not and so I
think that has to be with Ron and and no
that's reconsider is already passed that
the unretained has to be withdrawn and
the new motion rate to retain to follow
what the clerk said
uh to be clear and again the house clerk
is here uh go ahead Mr Clark
sorry Mr chairman uh representative that
is not correct we we immediately
returned to the previously passed motion
so the previously passed motion was to
retain so that motion is now what's
before you
the the motion that was made to
unretained was not a proper motion it
should not be it shouldn't it doesn't
need to be considered because it was not
a proper motion
thank you Miss Clerk so again uh the
a yes vote is to keep the original
retention uh status of this measure a no
vote means that you would like to see an
alternative motion uh made
um
are there any questions before we call
the roll on this
and again thank you Mr House clerk for
uh clarifying that procedure we want to
make sure we do this right
so we will now read the role on
um the original retention motion which
yes is to retain and know is to not
retain
representative Rollins no
representative Lundgren no
representative Thomas no
representative Harley no
Representative gagne no representative
piamonte
no
representative Platt no
representative Manion no representative
shurtleff yes
represent me no
representative Boris no
representative Fox
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative toll yes
representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative Siebert
Mr chair
no
am I able to change my vote I voted in
Era
I'll allow that if that's your wish yes
thank you
Boris is now a yes vote instead of a no
vote
thank you
eight years and ten Nays
okay so what that means is that the
original retention motion is uh no
longer in effect and we are looking for
a new motion for
hcr4 motion OTP with the amendment okay
uh is there a second second again uh
this is easy for you madam clerk uh
representative Manion made the motion
and the uh
second was made by representative gagne
um
and you mentioned an amendment
so the amendment here uh is uh replacing
the title so it says applying for the
convention of the states under Article 5
Constitutional Convention before it was
uh more or not clear
okay and that is amendment zero four
seven zero H correct
that is correct
okay uh at this time I wonder the same
thing that I did earlier with
representative Reed when she was here uh
as a courtesy if he wants to the prime
sponsor uh I'd like to invite you to
speak to this measure and also uh to
representative shirtless concern uh
which is a uh a fair question in terms
of
to take something off or to reconsider
something there needs to be some
substantive or something you need to
explain why there's some substantive new
information so that's up to you what
representative uh Wallace do you want to
speak to the situation if you would like
to uh you're welcome to speak up
certainly thank you Mr chair thank you
to the members of the committee
um as was addressed when I introduced
the bill there was a uh there was a
couple of minor drafting errors I
believe the bill was brought from 2016
when I first filed this and resubmitted
so the title was inaccurate
the analysis was inaccurate and the
prime sponsor District was inaccurate so
it's more than just
the name being different the way it was
introduced
um it had me listed as District 33 which
is actually representative Simpson
so the representative from District 33
is clearly not me I would argue that
representative Simpson is the Rose not
myself
um so that that
and the difference in the title caused
representative Smith who is seed who was
a substitute that day to
accurately read the bill that we were
asking Congress the New Hampshire house
would be asking Congress to term limit
itself which would be a ridiculous ask
and I would agree with her on that
analysis because the analysis from OLS
was inaccurate that's what's been
corrected the measure is clearly in
article five uh
convention request and the subject
matter of term limits is fully one-third
of hcr1 subject matter so the committee
voted quite strongly of a 15-4 for hcr1
the same boat I would expect would be
similar on HCR 4 because it's a you know
it's a single subject matter
parallel measure and that's that's the
extent of the um the amendment
thank you representative questions for
the prime sponsor while he's here if
he'll take questions if there are any
seeing none
uh thank you representative thank you to
the mo the emotion is to move the
amendment
um which is uh amendment I just read
that zero four seven four h
0 7 0 uh zero four seven four eight zero
four seven four eights is the amendment
it's been the motion and seconded is
there any further discussion on the
amendment
if there is none uh Madam clerk the vote
is on the amendment to
hcr4 Mr chairman uh representative gagne
the amendment
on hcr4 what I've got is zero four seven
zero H
uh Check Yes uh that's what I have as
well so let's make sure we're clear on
that the official
a designation for the amendment to hcr4
is zero four seven zero H okay thank you
zero four seven zero it's good catch or
up some gagne so we have that number
correct and the
motion again is to OTP on the amendment
and we will do the roll Madam Clerk
stand what question uh yes
representative
thank you Mr chair are we are we voting
on otpa or are we voting on just the
amendment the question is are we voting
on the amendment or or the otpa for the
full measure and this is just the
amendment thank you
Madam clerk on the amendment
OTP on the amendment
representative Rollins yes
representative London yes representative
Thomas yes representative Harley yes
representative gagne yes representative
Piemonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative minion yes
what do we put first Steve he's not here
not vote no vote
no vote no vote
clerk votes yes representative Boris yes
representative Fox
no
representative Hicks nope representative
toll
no
representative Brennan no representative
O'Neill
representative Siebert
represent uh Mr chair
yes
11 years six Nays and one abstention
thank you man yeah it would not be an
abstention uh if the member's not here
it's just the a blank okay we don't get
to abstain in the New Hampshire house
okay
um okay so the amendment has passed uh
it was a man and do you have another
motion
OTP as amended so in Israel second yes
there is
okay uh motion by representative Manion
to move this measure otpa with the
amendment just approved seconded by
representative gagne do you want to
speak to the uh amended motion so the
amended measure yeah as I was mentioning
before I support term limits I think
it's important a power check against the
government I'm I'm all for a Convention
of states to get that done because
they're sure not going to do it
themselves so I think we should uh vote
OTP
would anyone else like to speak to
representative I oppose it I just I
think it's Democratic to let people for
example I'm a big Bernie person if I
lived in Vermont I would vote for him
over and over again because I think he's
doing a great job and I think that is
the check and balance that people get to
vote for who they want to represent them
thank you representative uh
representative Hicks sure thank you Mr
chair I um I agree with my colleague
um and this is about as undemocratic as
you can imagine if you do not uh accept
the wish of the voters by preventing
them to have a candidate to run that
they wish to support we're essentially
saying it doesn't matter what the voters
think if we don't allow them vote for
their candidate
thank you representative
anyone else
was to speak to this motion of otpa
Representative gagne
opinion
I don't think it was ever meant
for Congress to have a lifetime job
whether you vote keep voting for these
people or not so I am in favor of term
limits
representative Platt I would just point
out that the president of the United
States is termed Limited
can't serve more than eight years
thank you representative
any other comments or discussion on the
motion
see none then Madam clerk if we could
again read the role the motion is otpa
on hcr4
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Harley yes representative gagne yes
representative piamonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative Manion yes clerk votes
yes representative Boris yes
representative Fox no representative
Hicks no representative toll no
representative Brennan no representative
O'Neill
representative sieber
Mr chair
yes
eleven six
okay so OTP a is approved eleven to six
vote
that brings us to our final two measures
uh yes
yes uh committee reports uh we'll uh
nail down before we everybody leaves say
who does the committee reports yes
we will help you representative Manion
typically the emotioner makes the report
and we will uh we'll try to spread that
load we'll we'll work that out later
good question
right last two measures are HR 15 and HR
16 hr15 is relative to affirming support
against the establishment of a state
religion uh referencing Marxism
um do I have a motion on this measure HR
15.
if we don't have emotion then what do we
do
um
Mr chair being a motion Ito
representative P Monte motions itl do we
have a second for that Ito
thank you representative Siebert who
seconds
the itl motion on HR 15. Russo pimani
would you care to speak to your itl
motion
uh thank you Mr chair
um
I I feel this bill has a appeal to a
small group of individuals and and I'm
not saying that in any disparaging way I
just don't think it's as popular as it
is uh as other things should be okay
thank you representative uh who is this
oh representative sieber you seconded
this would you care to speak to your
seconding motion
oh sorry
but I believe that it was
um just a little I mean yeah no offense
but it was
you know if you're gonna put this in as
establishing it as a religion you would
have to put a lot of other ideas as well
that we have that are you know whether
they're mainstream or not so
yeah
thank you representative would anyone
would anyone else care to speak uh
representative gagne
I'm voting
ought to pass on this not because I
necessarily agree with the this bill of
this resolution but
um I would like to keep it off consent
so this gentleman can have his day in
court so to speak to speak to
that representative Belcher can have an
opportunity to present his case before
the general court
thank you representative I understand
your sentiments and that would be up to
him uh if this is not on consent uh
the process that there may be a floor a
Voice vote
um uh that process would be at the
discretion of the uh the Full House
other comments
or questions
say none the motion is to itl and
expedient to legislate on hf15
uh in Madam clerk if he would read the
role for that please
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Harley yes representative gagne
no
representative piamonte
yes
representative Platt yes
representative Manion no
clerk votes yes
representative Boris yes representative
Fox yes representative Hicks yes
representative toll yeah representative
Brennan yes representative O'Neill
representative Siebert
Mr chair
no
14 years and three Nays
thank you madam clerk that brings us to
our final measure
of the day which is H.R 16 relative to
the Internal Revenue Service
I'm looking for some sort of emotion on
this resolution on this measure
and you don't have to write the blurb
if you don't
want to take care of it but we need it
we need a
emotion eruption of gagne
I move itl
on this resolution
motion is to itl on hr16 do we have a
second for that
I'll second that was that representative
pimani
representative pimani seconds that uh By
the way when I say blurb I meant to say
committee report
uh okay represent getting would you care
to speak to your itl motion on HR 16.
much Mr chairman uh
for me it's pretty convoluted you're
gonna you're gonna go tell the internal
revenue revenue service you're going to
tell them don't be doing what you're
doing or
it poses questions to the Internal
Revenue Service uh a resolution will do
that I know what's going to happen to
this house resolution if it should pass
when it gets to uh Internal Revenue
Service it's going to be a circular file
so let's let's get rid of it right now
before and and representative Gerhart
can bring something else or explain it
even better
then I can understand it
thank you representative uh the second
motion represent P Money anything to add
thank you Mr chair
um I I kind of agree
I think that uh um it needs more work to
to be palatable from for me to
folk positive on this
thank you representative
anyone else representative Manion
I'm I won't object to consent if I'm the
lone wolfier but like I like asking
questions of the IRS they should be
asked lots of questions
could you could you repeat that I want
to make sure you're interested
I'm not opposed to asking these
questions from uh presented by the bill
sponsor to the IRS
thank you other comments
I'll make one comment uh this measure
had something like 23 whereas which is
typical of a resolution whereas this
where is that and a lot of the whereas
is uh I agreed with but uh not all 23 of
them
um some of the whereas is uh I I wasn't
uh in sync with and uh so I guess the
point is uh if any anyone is ever doing
resolution uh if you're going to have
20s with 30 whereas you want to make
sure I would recommend that those
whereases are where whereas that people
can uh agree agree on
so that said anyone else
okay saying No Hands uh Madam clerk the
motion on H.R 16 is to itl uh if you
would please read the role
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Harley yes representative gagne yes
representative piamonte
yes representative Platt yes
representative Manion no
clerk votes yes representative Boris yes
representative Fox yeah representative
Hicks yes representative toll
representative Brennan yes
representative O'Neill
representative Siebert
cheer
yes
tonight
sixteen to one sixteen years one a
16-1 the ital motion carries
and that is our 17th and final measure
that has been assigned to this committee
uh I want to thank uh the subs again and
the folks who've been to the sessions
we've had last month and this month uh
thank you very for your your great work
uh I've been on other committees and uh
every uh exact session or hearings we've
had I've always left here uh feeling
good about our work that doesn't always
happen so uh thank everybody for your
work and we'll see if there's anything
from uh the Senate crossover in April uh
last term we had a couple uh we'll see
what comes so we may have some business
in April or not and uh again uh thank
you all and uh representative uh Rollins
uh reps them in and did you no objection
okay if there were represent Manion did
vote uh in the negative on that so if
there are no objections uh thank you
represent Rollins we will uh put that on
consent does anyone else have anything
else for the good of the committee yeah
Mr chairman representative gagne Mr
chairman
question is do I know if we're getting a
second committee bill here uh nothing
that nothing has come to me definite on
that uh if if that were to happen we'd
let everybody know immediately
good question anything else
reps and grounds yes in case this is our
last committee meeting here I'd like to
say it that I'm very impressed with how
we've all got along on this committee
everybody's been cordial it's been a
wonderful experience for everybody and I
hope to see that this continues in the
future thank you all
thank you Mr Vice chair yes as I said
before uh I'm sure we've all had days
where we left this building uh not so
happy but as I said I appreciate
everybody working together this has been
the case here
if there's is there anything else for
the committee
if not I'm going to take my new gavel
and uh I'll adjourn this executive
session
thank you
the blurbs yeah mostly I need to just
see I need to talk to Russian Emmanuel
uh